[Musique]
merci de nous retrouver pour un VIP
complètement spécial aujourd'hui j'ai la
grande joie d'être accompagné du
directeur de la rédaction de tv78 en la
personne de vous dire Patrice carmous
voilà qui est là et de Charlotte Martin
qui est là alors elle est yvelinoise
bien sûr vous êtes de quel village
mademoiselle nois le roi vous êtes de
nois leoi une ville ah c'est une ville
de de 7000 habitants des zlines ouais
des zlines bien sû c'est principal voilà
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on est là parce
que un jour au au tournant d'un couloir
Patrice souvenez-vous vous m'avez confié
votre amour des pâes des couloirs qui
tournent c'était un ang d'accord enre de
portes j'ie dire de PES vous m'avez dit
j'aimerais j'adore les pattes et
j'aimeraisadore les pattes hein vous me
le confirmez j'ai pas changé d'avis
depuis bon et vous m'avez dit euh je
rêveraai de savoir en faire et voilà
parce que j'achète des pâtes tout de
fête mais si je pouvais en faire ça ça
vous réjouirait hein surtout peut-être
pour F VI quoi mais j'aime ça j' doute
j'en doute pas alors du coup ben j'ai
pensé à vous et j'ai une super solution
en la personne de Charlotte parce que
Charlotte vient d'entamer une nouvelle
vie maintenant elle s'est reconvertie
elle est traiteur et parmi les activités
et les les produits et tout ça qu'elle
propose à à ses clients il y a notamment
atelier pâte alors cet atelier Bâ il
peut se faire pas malin entre amis au
travail en team building exactement pour
reserer les liens entre collègues voilà
si besoin est c'est pas mal ça rien
qu'une
pte c'ester comm ça non mais c'est super
parce qu'après on déguste ben oui alors
du coup on s'est dit bah tiens on va
faire plaisir à Pat et on va lui prendre
c'est mon petit cadeau cade de Noël
voilà alors Charlotte elle est d'origine
italienne oui oui du nord de l'Italie
c'est assez lointain mais c'est vrai que
dans ma famille on aime les
pâtes famale voilà exactement on fait
les pâtes tous ensemble alors comment
vous avez fait pour vous former parce
que c'est un peu nouveau cette activité
alors l'année dernière non il y a 2 ans
j'ai passé mon CAP Cuisine en candidanim
ah génial et voilà j'ai commencé à
travailler un peu sur des tournages à
faire du cating pour des shootings des
tournages des choses comme ça et et
voilà et ensuite une fois que j'ai eu
mon CPP je ne savais pas où j'allais
j'étais un peu perdu à ce momentlà dans
mes projets parce que j'avais un projet
entrepreneurial mais je savais pas
encore ce que ça allait devenir du coup
je me suis dit mais il faut que je
quitte Paris je pars avec ma petite
voiture en Italie pour 3 mois donc voilà
et les gens me disaient mais qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire ben je vais manger des
pâtes pendant 3 mois et euh et voilà
donc ça a été une super super expérience
et j'ai mangé des pâtes tous les
jours rest P voà exactement avec un peu
de sport bien
sûr et alors vous avez rencontré des
chefs italiens vous êtes vous avez fait
amichiia comme ils disent voilà
exactement et ils vous ont donné des
recettes exactement en fait j'étais en
colocque avec des chefs et j'ai
rencontré plein d'Italiens qui
travaillaient en cuisine et et là-bas en
fait c'est vraiment le partage était en
Ombrie donc il a une région qui est très
très accueillante et et j'ai frappé un
peu à toutes les portes et on m'a on m'a
gentiment ouvert pour me faire découvrir
du coup la gastronomie italienne génial
alors le chef italien est généreux vous
avez appris beaucoup de choses parce que
on dit vous voulez pas tout le monde
sait en faire quoi en gros euh alors
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses surtout
au niveau je pense du choix des produits
euh parce que la cuisine italienne tout
le monde pense saoir la faire mais
finalement c'est une cuine de précision
et ils ont une une agriculture qui est
incroyable avec plein de variétés donc
chaque variété correspond à une recette
et cetera d'accord donc vous qu chose
quand même et puis vous avez aussi
appris à les façonner voilà faire
fabriquer des pâtes fraîches bien sûr un
tour de main quand même faisais déjà
mais pardon excusez-moi mais est-ce que
justement parce que c'est compliqué
quand même de de de faire des pâtes il
faut il faut cet appareil fa vous allez
nous montrer je pense mais euh ça change
beaucoup les choses de faire les pâ fr
par par rapport au au pâtes qu'on trouve
dans le commerce euh alors ça dépend
pour quelle recette
moi je pense que les recettes par
exemple à base de sauce tomate il vaut
mieux privilégier une pâte sèche parce
qu'ensuite on va la la cuire encore dans
sa sauce avec le jus de cuisson et
cetera la pâte fraîche elle correspond
plutôt à des sauces beuré huilé voilà
des choses un peu plus grasses et qui
vont accentuer en fait dans lesquels on
va révéler vraiment le goût de la de la
pâte ouais oui des sauce peut-être plus
rapide à faire moins impactante aussi ou
simple ou plusite fait déguste génial
alors aujourd'hui ma chère Charlotte
vous nous proposez pour commencer avec
Patrice quelle recette alors aujourd'hui
on va faire des tagatelles au beurre de
sauge ok alors on va faire un beurre
roussi dans notre petite casserole pour
la sauce pour la sauce et ensuite on va
venir faire revenir nos feuilles de
sauge dans le beurre c'est très simple
mais il faut que le beurre roussisse un
peu pour donner ce petit goût no
qui va tout changer d'accord pour faire
grossir ça veut dire quoi on le on le
met à feu dou non à feu à feu moyen
ouais feu moyen un peu longtemp d'accord
dès que ça commence un peu à rossir faut
pas que ça devienne noir Patrice
attention non pas
le chose voilà alors du coup comment on
commence parce qu'il faut les fabriquer
al on on va démarrer donc déjà la
recette est très simple un œuf pour 100
g de farine je vais prendre le plus gros
pourquoi bah parce que c'est pour moi
voilà c'est plaisir non parce que sinon
quand l'œuf est trop gros il faut
rajouter de la farine donc on tombe un
peu moins juste donc là vous prenez à
vos
fourchettes on va on va battre on va
battre notre un petit
peu on avait pas de grand bol donc on va
essayer de reverser la farine dans ce
petit bol voilà je pense que là c'est
bon vous mettez toute la farine alors là
il y a combien à peu près pour un œuf il
y a 100 g de farine pour un œuf pas de
sel pas d'huile rien du tout mis à côté
ça c'est bizarreve j'ai bien fait de
prendre le c'est un petit peu grave a
bien mesuré c'est une cuisine de
précision dit Patrice ça y est il y a 10
gr récupérer
vos et là on B encore ouais et là voilà
vous mélangez il faut que la farine
s'imprègne bien de l'œuf voilà et donc
ça après on va qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
ensuite vous allez pétrir pétrir ça
cl j'ai main mais là vous vous mettez
votre main Patrice et vousz remué chez
Patrice je je ne sais pas je on va
voiras c'est bien c'est très voilà on va
faire une boule et on va la peine pé si
il faut faire une petite boue Patrice
oui un pâton sinon ça va faire des NIS
Patrice ça ce sera un autre cours la
prochaine fois c'est ny n c'est pommes
de terre on est d'accord d'acc j'ai un
peu plein les main mais on peut en faire
avec
d'autres
c'est pas mal par rapport à d'autres
c'est un B déf ah c'est vachement bien
vous écoutez moi je fais les jours par
il faut réussir pour manger hein la
vache moi ch mange sa
boule la merde vous voulez qu'on qu'on
échange je ne sais pas parce
que faudrait racler un peu attends je
vais lu racler les doigts pardon qu' y
en a autant dans les mains que pe
permettre oui si vous vouz
est-ce que c'est dommage voilà j'ai
compris pourquoi j'achète des pattes
toute F parce que est-ce qu'on peut
lâcher la boule dans la la lâcher la
boule 2 secondes j'aime beaucoup lâcher
la boule moi voilà de temps en temps
faut savoir lâcher la boule reprendre
les choses un petit peu je permets he
oui oui oui bien sûr moi j'aime bien
quand les élèves prennent le contrôle
comme ça bah oui alors je suis pas très
bon dans le pétrissage c'est quoi non on
vit faire quoi le pétrissage pétrissage
parce que à mon avis
il y a pas assez de farine dans votre
dans votre truc voyez et du coup elle
vous a collé au doigt alors qu'elle
n'aurait pas d d'accord voilà ça va jeis
pas ou c'est bien non je te laisse y
aller d'ailleurs tu vas y aller quoi tu
vas n laisser ouis c'est bon là bon on
va dire que c'est bien est-ce que vous
voulez vous mettre de la farine sur les
mains vous êtes très bon dans le
péin dans le péin c'est ma force voilà
ouais on se lave les mains se laver les
mains ouais on se Frot un peu les mains
ouais voilà et après tu vois hop atts je
pe-être faire les autres en attendant
pour pas qu'elle sèche continue à pétrir
tiens tenez ah oui ou oui
cha encore que dans la chambre je t'aime
dans la cuisine rien ne vaut les mains
d'une femme dans la farine
génial magnifique regardez si j'ai bien
réussi c'est magnifique petite mais très
belle tent c'estelle qui a tout fait je
vais vous embaucher en Pat alors ensuite
vous sortez du bol la vôre elle est
moins bien allez hop et là Patrice vous
pouvez aller sur la table comme ça avec
le point on peut faire un balancier avec
ses
jambes en même temps on change de pied
on peut changer de pied bah oui parce
que sinon on aura une fesse plus grosse
que l'autre
trop cl faut qu'elle se repose
temp au 30 minutes la propriété de qu'on
est en train de satter chez
sur c'est vraiment une surprise elle
rentre
pourentôt oui d'ailleurs nous remercions
Alexandra s
pas là une jeuneelinoise aussi de de nos
connaissances la remercie mais elle sait
pas qu'on est là
donc découvrir
cl Patrice est-ce que vous pouvez me
passer le film plastique s'il vous plaît
ah
oui un film comme ça pass un petit film
F j' Mar pass un film italien oui bien
sûr c'est quoi votre film italien
préféré affreux ça les méchant j'avais
adorer ce film c'était mais sinon y a ah
l'incompris c'était magnifique oh
c'était tellement triste oh j'ai autant
pleuré de ma vie il y a un film récent
qui s'appelle l'enlèvement vous l'avez
vu magnifique oui c'est vrai ou ah faut
que j'y aille alors alors merci alors
maintenant on va les laisser poser
au moins 30 minutes moi j'aime bien les
faire poser tous une nuit mais là on va
peut-être pas rester là la nuit bah on a
pas de fil on a rien c'est ça on a plus
rien pass ti je vous passe un
film super et donc on va les faire
reposer bon je les mets au frigo mais
c'est pas obligatoire
d'accord alors après et pendant que ça
repose on va démarrer notre sauce ok
d'accord la sauce la sauge on va
commencer par prendre du beurre il y en
a combien là ou tout ça euh là là on a
bien 150 g de beurre mais tout ça alors
moi les doses que je recommande c'est à
peu près 40 g de beur par personne pour
cette recette d'accord sinon c'est un
peu sec bon c'est une recette qui est
assez grasse même parfois je mets 50 ça
ça dépend à qui j'ai affire d'accord euh
donc feuille de sauge citron et alors le
citron ça va être vraiment pour le final
pour zester sur nos pâtes ça fait un
petit côté ah oui
bien ça oui ça allège un peu tout
d'ailleurs vous me racontiez votre
formation en Italie c'était ça que vous
aviez aussi remarqué leur façon de
zester du citron ouais sur beaucoup de
plats citron et d'autres agrumes c'est
vrai qu'ils ont tendance à à pas mal pas
mal faire ça util ça et du coup vous
vous l'avez utilisz vous-même dans dans
votre cuisine en tant que traiteur dans
les plats et dans les pièces que vous
proposez pour les buffets exactement
voilà c'était une
petite pas travaillé ni par contre on a
pas le droit de se laver les mains
jusqu'à la fin très bien ça nous dérange
pas et là on va mettre nos feuilles
dedans elle m'a eu donc maintenant on
fait cuire la la sauge dans le beurre
voilà on fait voilà combien de temps à
peu près bah on la regarde c'est vrai
que je suis un peu nulle avec les temps
mais on voit là je vais mettre un peu
plus il faut qu'elle soit cuite quoi bon
Patrice je vous laisse vérifier la sauge
un peu la mélanger de temps en temps
prendre ça alors je
va ça on vire ouais ça on vire P belle
ah tu PRS encore un petit peu ou pas
ouais encore un petit peu c'est bien
ah ça va être bon et là il y a l'odeur
de la sauge c'est comme de c'est comme
de la truffe hein la sauge c'est un un
parfum très très
prononcé regardez c'est ça sent très
très bon alors le beurre est roussi
comme on le voit il est pas noir encore
il est juste roussi et la sauge la sauge
est cuite quoi pratiquement et ça sent
extrêmement bon c'est divin hein il y a
une odeur
bon je crois que c'est bon là ah c'est
magnifique ça va être super là on voit
que le beurre il est bien noisette la
sauge elle est elle est
frite non non vous pouvez la laisser en
fait on va se servir de
cette cle pour nos pâtes à la fin on va
tout mélanger la c'est vrai fait ça bien
en tout cas ouis c'est magnifique
pasé plus dans dans là je viens de
regarder figurez-vous que vos PES sont
prêtes ah génial ah donc je vais aller
chercher frig elles ont bien reposé ou
là là on voit que la couleur a un peu
changé ouais c'est mag ça c'est signe de
repos ah c'est bien ça ça c'est celle de
Patrice la reconnais ça c'est la tienne
la plus belle c'est la plus belle pas lo
pas loin parce que non elle est très
très forte reposer la moins bien
on allez on défilme bon qu'est-ce qu'on
fait concrètement alors donc là on va se
prendre on va séparer sa pâte en deux
d'accord on va faire des petites boules
comme ça donc là j'ai réglé la machine
sur le CRAN le plus large donc ça c'est
un laminoir c'est une machine italienne
donc on est sur le CRAN le plus large ça
va nous permettre d'étaler notre pâte
boule boule on a dit
pârice bouboule une bouboulee la
bouboule mais vous pouvez la préétaler
comme ça ah bon ah et aprs on l'écrase
alors ell soit aual voilà vous faites un
faites ce que vous pouvez ça c'est bien
comme ça
ouais là c'est c'est magnifique un carré
ouais c'est bien un carré tu serais pour
un carré ouais un carré c'est bien ça
vous arrange un carré tac comme ça faut
nous dire nous on attend les ordres et
puis on fait ce que ce qu'il faut hein
on sait pas si fait un carré rond bon il
y en a un qui est pas mal on dirait une
[Rires]
patate c'est magnifique toc alors donc
une fois qu'on a notre carp non c'est
très bien c'est simplement pour aider la
machine pour pas qu'elle force trop
pauvre bête ouci ouais donc là je le
mets ici tu il a un peu l'ital ah ouais
magnifique on est vraiment des artistes
alors Véronique est-ce que tu veux
essayer al attends je fais ça ah oui tu
l'as bien fait toi attends attends et
dans quel sens ouais voilà là ta
manivelle elle part bien faut pas
appuyer parce que sinon ça reste de
coller oh mon
dieu ah oui oh bravo magnifique
incroyable mal à la tête c'est souverain
pour le mal de crâne non c'est
incroyable on dirait un tour de magie oh
mais c'est un tour de
magie
vousou et on va tourner la dans ce sens
là ouais
super qu' fait un
effortentre regarde
ça arri
magnifique bon ça c'est le beau de
Charlotte on continue
as vu la forme de ce Charlotte elle a
pratiquement tu encore allez moi je peux
y aller plus vite alors bah ouaisant que
maintenant que je sais que ça faitant
maîtrise hop là encore un tour de magie
incroyable tu peux faire n'importe quoi
d'abord ça fait quand même un truc bien
après voilà donc pas la peine de se
mettre la r arrivé maintenant je passe
au cran numéro 2 de nashine ah
difficulté difficult et là on va le
faire plus fort
et avec un rouleau à paâtisserie vache
ah oui je Tu tires en même temps oh le
je vois la qui arrive là et magnifque
superbe donc là on va
prendre rajouter un on va rajouter un
élément alors comment on le met hop
voilà on décale notre
manivelle sur la partie découpe de
tagatelle d'accord comment on sait c'est
ça bah là on voit la forme donc là tu
vois que c'est des tagateles et là c'est
des
spaghettis un mode d'emploi aussi hein
si jamais oui sinon et hop et on
récupère les pâtes ici Magi génial tu
veux pas les mettre là et là ah tu fais
des nfine un petit peu bah normalement
faut les faire sécher mais là on n pas
de séchoir on va les mettre comme ça on
les met pas en nid en nid bah tu sais
les tateles quand elles sont sèches ah
oui tu peux les mettre en nid aussi
ouais regarde regarde il se débrouille
très bien tout seul se débrouille très
bien tout seul faites la faites la
première
que voilà
voilà moi je fais l'accueil
oh accue
accueille
voilà c'est bon on on peut les cuirez
combien de temps combien de temps ça se
met pe près 2 minutes ou la vache 2
minutes
ex qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
pendant ce chronomètre ah j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de j'ai rien moi non plus mais
on il sont peut-être un peu collé
normalement il faut les faire sécher et
là on on pas le temps là non on a pas le
temps parce que sinon on se faitoler par
la production alors c'est parti voilà on
pe un peu les décer ça c'est une pince à
pâte on va les laisser cuire minut minut
minutes à partir du moment ça reboue ou
pas ou 2 minutes on non 2 minutes
les pâtes fraîches c'est très très
rapide si on les cuit trop c'est
vraiment pas bon quoi ça fait de
pâte tac donc tu es sûr de vous êtes sûr
de votre coup là ouais là c'est bon
génial
voilà alors la sauce donc la sauce là je
vais ah ben non pas pas dans le les
goûtoi
et et là pour les mélanger avec la pince
à pâte avec la pince à pâte donnez-moi
la pince à pâte hop là on est un peu Doé
comme on VO qu'elles ont une belle
texture elles sont splendides hein c'est
vrai ah ou RAR aussi Bell bon rarement
fait partie des meilleures équipes ben
oui oui vraiment un talent incroyable ah
ben voilà alors on met du parmesan avec
plaisir allez hop là mag
génial et après on zeste alors Patrice
vous n'avez pas eu de parmesan non mais
un peu
parmesan un peu
de vous voulez essayer B oui je veux non
vous le faire si vous
voulez c'est joli hein ouais c'est très
beau c'est petit cop de une photo c'est
magnifique moi je prends une photo parce
que là j'ai rarement vu des assiettes
aussi belles avec leses élèves
ouis elle est jolie C c'est bon en plus
c'est bon
c'est très bon c'est bon on va voir ça
vous AZ bien ont une consistance bien
faire je trouve he ah oui alors j'arrive
pas la cuisson la cuisson est
parfaite bonissimo ça y est Patrice va
se mettre à par italien
maintenant
patri est bien on est bien nous on est
bien merci pas la bouche pleine c'est TR
mal
élevé re les dents merci Patrice Merci à
VOUS
r je vais ressortir ma machine pas d ce
soir appelez Charlotte si vous oublie un
truc bien s elle fait vous pouvez venir
voil si on vous appelle
vous m'appelez SOS passe je sais plus
comment on fait Charlotte j'arrive tout
de suite non mais c'est non mais vous
allez vous pouvez aller chez des ouis g
génial aprs on pe faire des accord est-
est-ce que les gens peuvent être chez
eux quand vous faites les trucs ou alors
vous faites comme ici vous squattez j'ai
à
squatter c'est concept non bravo si
c'est pas fini bravo c'est un délice ah
merci beaucoup merci Charlotte comment
ça s'appelle votre entreprise alors
c'est Carlotta food Carlotta food tout
simplement sur Instagram
@carlotta.food et et pourquoi pas Carlot
Cina ah ben je vais peut-être changer de
nte c'est pas une mauvaise idéeah
oui et par mail
charlottemarttin.r@gmail.com bon tout ça
on le mettra au bon endroit merci de
nous avoir suivi écoutez faites comme
nous c'est délicieux et à très bientôt
[Musique]
merci